bon oui avec vous aviez un casting cinq
étoiles fois il y avait dix à
jean-michel et kelly que ce soit sur le
plateau de ppp ou dans un autre pays ou
encore à dos de chameau eh bien chacun
reste comme il est et ça c'est rassurant
toutes les images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fabien lecoeuvre de mes petits chemins
c'est normal qu'ils aient mon chapeau
c'est tellement minime
[Musique]
thébaux cyril la virée lawrence d'arabie
on pas les séries les majestueux qui
tiennent une main l'autre main sur la
cuisse et c'est vraiment la classe
[Musique]
mais ta gueule les plans berges et bien
je vais bien je viens aussi caler le
vert c'est une belle que tu aimes bien
la couleur le vert
c'est jésus c'est jésus jésus subis tu
vélo il va faire des miracles je viens
et le vieil il est beau il est beau ou
laid quoi photo il ya eu bien sûr
lunettes ou le canasson de l'air et
cunek moule qui aura joué
c'est grâce au badge en partie samedi
ouais d'accord ça vaut merci alors on a
été très bien accueilli je voulais
remercier des équipes de la ram ainsi
que le directeur de l'office national
des aéroports
un grand merci à nedjma pour les
activités pour la sequenza bout merci à
alexis houle et sylvia roule bien sûr
pour nous avoir accueilli au palais
roule et merci au restaurant la le
tongien
on a très bien manger là bas vous avez
d'autres chaussures homme marrakech bien
sûr alors isabelle comment le vin va
très bien a annoncé vous êtes une femme
de lettres qui a beaucoup de vocabulaire
on peut avoir plus de retour pour
entendre eux pour qu'ils nous vous
mettrez on dirait qu'on est dans un taxi
derrière bon on le sait que vous êtes
une femme de lettres sauf quand vous
êtes impressionné et oui là vous n'avez
que plus que deux mots à la bouche
c'est une vraie sympathie dit ça
tu vois c'est la taupe or de leucate
c'est la zone et de leucate
[Musique]
le tableau il est splendide et alors là
la statue moi je suis une fanatique des
bons moi qui le suis une fanatique de
cette époque parce qu'en plus rien ta
niche une thématique des arbres très
très très beau qu'est ce que c'est beau
c'est qu'est ce que c'est magnifique
qu'est ce que ces boues par une sorte de
jardin d'hiver parce que c'est vous qui
se dévouent magnifique qu'est ce si beau
ça magnifique audi dans happy même est
où sa magnifique qu'est ce que c'est
beau tout tout est magnifique c'est pas
possible janvier c'est pas croyable
tout est magnifique tout était
magnifique ça va alors ça c'est la
boucle obligatoire à chaque fois voilà
ils ont fait une boucle voila voila
c'est très bien on a d'autres choses
pour que oui un cyril mois la belge
fonçait qu'au maroc on parlait arabe
bah ouais mais a priori la hchouma je me
suis trompé d'endroit belle puisque non
la langue officielle dans le désert pour
tp fameux lit ça reste verlan oui on
regarde c'est quoi le baiia elle
apporter les titres peugeot c'est là que
port de leucate c'est la zone b2 le cas
pourquoi ben laden chez nous c'est ouf
et c'est le début d'un muffin saturent
il veut vraiment évolué moins que true
blood chez moi tu te tiens un pull sylla
et ut sow tu t'emballes inc
on devrait faire une ce combat de
chameau c'est vrai qu'il avec multiplie
les tisons qu'elle comprend ce qu'il
sait faire
[Applaudissements]
on a fait le boulot sans relâche à la
paix il en vit bien sûr pas question
d'aller au maroc sans assister un petit
show des magnifiques dans ce salon
cherche on me taxe est un plaisir
[Musique]
la farandole de desserts
avec le même module va rigoler
mais là je rêve belgian legends
arrivés sur place libre
j'ai peur de sa poche ce berceau
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui ce que vous savez que mamie zaza est
une héroïne mais oui elle a des super
pouvoirs
non elle veut sans dormir n'importe où
les téléspectateurs aiment bien ça lévis
[Musique]
qui comme vous c'est magnifique
manuel valls 6 et 48 heures sans dormir
et 48 ans également sentir